hello and welcome my name is kimberly
martin i am an applications chemist ii
and technical service specialist for
waters of icam
today i will be discussing mastering
complex samples using immunoaffinity
column sample prep with hplc and uplc
in this presentation we will cover what
are mycotoxins
the background of mycotoxins and
chemical structures
ecological parameters in mycotoxin
production
what ecological factors affect
mycotoxins
new solution for the complex matrix
introducing the afla test wbsr plus
column
uplc and hplc results in the discussion
of those results
and advantages of the aflatest wbsr plus
immunoaffinity column
what are mycotoxins
well they are the toxic secondary
metabolites of several fungal species
including the three shown here
penicillium
aspergillus and fusarium molds
aflatoxin is one of if not the most
carcinogenic naturally occurring
substance known to man
it has a number of different forms and
is found in many common foods
like corn peanuts
tree nuts
and in animal feed components like
cottonseed
it can have a huge impact all the way
along the food chain
other mycotoxins such as okra toxin a
occur at much lower levels
but it occurs in a wide variety of
commodities including dried fruits such
as raisins
which are an ingredient in a number of
common foods such as barley
soy products
which again can be a component of animal
feed and even coffee
and we know how essential coffee is
and that's a concern because although
the amounts might be relatively low it
can accumulate in the blood and other
tissues and cause other problems
all of the mycotoxins have different
impacts although they are in some way
detrimental to either human or animal
health or both
some are carcinogenic as mentioned some
have effects on the immune system
some might cause types of neuropathy
others cause things like beak rot and
poultry and cause a number of other
problems with other livestock
another mycotoxin deoxynol
is also known as vamatoxin
that causes problems in many wheat-based
products
and we really want to avoid
these mycotoxins getting into any part
of the food chain
now we will go over mycotoxin chemical
structures
shown here are the structures for
fumonosyn b1
b2
b3 and ochrotoxin a
fumonosins which were discovered in 1988
in south africa
differentiate by a hydroxyl group
fumonosines
predominantly occur in cereal grains
especially in maize
mechanistic studies suggest disruption
of lipid metabolism as being the mode of
action for fumonosyn b1 mediated
toxicity
fumonosin b1 is not mutagenic but is
capable of introducing reactive oxygen
species that could lead to dna damage
fumonosin b1 caused effects in some
developmental and reproductive studies
a slight
significant impact of ocratoxin is that
it occurs in such a wide variety of
commodities such as raisins barley soy
products and coffee
in amounts that may be relatively low
however significant amounts may
accumulate in the blood and other
tissues
because it derives from potential
different sources
ochrodoxin produces necrosis of the
proximal
tubular
epithelium and then is released whereby
it is reabsorbed by albumin and
continues to circulate via the
bloodstream
okra toxin is a carcinogen in rats and
mice
and it is suspect agent of a human
disease named balkan endemic
nephropathy
that affects the kidneys which tumors
are often associated
other mycotoxin chemical structures are
shown here including t2 toxin
ht2 toxin deoxy navalnol navalnol
and xarellanone
t2 and ht2 toxins are members of the
fungal metabolites known as
trichrothesenes
corn wheat barley oats rice rye and
other crops have been reported to
contain the t2 toxin
the major attribute of the t2 toxin and
other trichotins is that they inhibit
protein synthesis
which is followed by a secondary
disruption of dna and rna synthesis
it can decrease antibody levels
immunoglobulins and certain other
humoral factors
the effects include weight loss or poor
weight gain
bloody
necrosis or beak lesions and
hemorrhaging
t2 results from an esterification of the
hydroxyl group of ht2 with acetic acid
nib
and dawn known as navalny and
deoxynebolanol
differentiate between each other by the
presence of a hydroxyl group
in the volanol
deoxynol is also known as vomitoxin
xorellanone is chemically a phenolic
resoric
acid lactone in fact it is often present
in combination with the oxynovalanol
the compound is mostly found in corn
however it is found also in other
important crops such as wheat
barley sorghum and rye
zarellanone is the primary toxin causing
infertility
abortion or other breeding problems in
mammals
lastly we have the mycotoxin chemical
structures for aflatoxins listed below
as you can see aflatoxin b1 b2 g1 g2 m1
and m2 which is the primary focus of the
immunoaffinity column that i will be
discussing today
aflatoxins are produced by two species
of the genus
aspergillus
aspergillus flavus and aspergillus
parasiticus
aflatoxins are
genotoxic and carcinogenic and can cause
both acute and chronic toxicity in
humans
aflatoxin b1 and b2
differ for a double bond and the same is
true for aflatoxin g1 and g2 along with
m1 and m2
corn cottonseed peanuts and tree nuts
are main crops affected the presence
innate fluorescent properties aflatoxin
is the most carcinogenic naturally
occurring substance known to man
in summary mycotoxins are health
hazard-causing compounds
and it is not a case
that they have been ranked as the most
important chronic dietary risk factor
higher than
synthetic contaminants plant toxins food
additives or pesticide residues
one very interesting thing about
mycotoxins is that they are not
ubiquinous
you know you may find the mold in your
commodity wherever it may be and not the
toxin or vice versa
the mold may have been eliminated but
the mycotoxin while you can't see it is
still there
so why is that
well different ecological parameters or
stressors affect mycotoxin production
by the differential fungal species
mentioned earlier
and those include moisture
spore load
the temperature of the environment
if there's any other bugs that have
infected the plant
or the storage area
what substrate they are growing on
oxidization levels
how long something has been stored
maybe some mechanical damage that
occurred during harvest
or insect damage and one important note
is that organic crops or crops that have
not been treated with fungicides are
especially vulnerable
to contamination by mycotoxins
so there are many strategies to growers
and producers
that they can use to minimize risks to
the crops and the products
for example not growers can reduce the
percentage of early split nuts by
irrigation management
and avoiding tree stress
early harvest also cuts down on
naval orange worm damage
using a rod stock that minimizes early
split nuts and carefully
use
dormancy breaking chemicals can also
prevent early splits
processors can reduce aflatoxin levels
by drying nuts as soon as possible after
arrival
sorting can remove contaminated in-shell
nuts based on the shell discoloration
shell size and presence of insect frass
storage at proper moisture levels and
avoiding post-harvest rehydration will
also prevent contamination
as we have discussed aflatoxins are
carcinogenic mycotoxins that have
adverse health effects on both humans
and animals
consuming contaminated food and feed
a method has been developed for the
highly sensitive and selective
determination of regulated aflatoxins
in a wide range of commodities
the extraction of aflatoxins from
representative commodities of interest
corn wheat oats red chili
black pepper
cocoa and a traditional chinese medicine
was performed using a solvent extraction
then immunoaffinity column cleanup on
the new aflatest wb sr plus
immunoaffinity column
chromatographic separation was
demonstrated using both the waters hplc
alliance and the waters uplc acuity
h-class plus platforms using
fluorescence detection
supported with post-column
derivatization and large flow cell
respectively the performance of the
method was evaluated through replicate
analysis of spiked test portions
of seven different matrices
overall recovery was shown to be
excellent between 92 and 116
with relative standard deviations lower
than 8 percent
the method was found to be specific as
no interference peaks were observed for
blank samples
the method has been demonstrated as
suitable for monitoring compliance with
regulatory limits set for aflatoxins in
food commodities globally
we have discussed mycotoxins in detail
and why we need to test for aflatoxins
in our food supply
our variety of testing solutions exist
for the determination of alpha toxins
ranging from easy to use rapid tests
which can be which can be used at the
point of production
to lab-based reference methods that are
more time-consuming but can be used to
provide a more comprehensive view of the
level of contamination
determination of actual toxins is a
challenging task due to the complexity
of the matrix
often with high lipid content
the low concentrations in which these
compounds are usually present and the
strict low regulatory limits
the combination of
cleaning up
using amino affinity columns based on
antibodies and analysis by hplc with
fluorescence
has been a prerequisite step to achieve
the desired sensitivity and selectivity
and has been successfully used as a
cost-effecting way to check compliance
with the regulatory limits for
aflatoxins for many years
vicam launched a new product
the aflatest wbsr plus immunoaffinity
column which can endure a high
concentration of organic solvent
while maintaining excellent recoveries
the objective of this study was to
examine the performance of using vicam's
aflatest wbsr plus immunoaffinity
columns with two separate hplc upoc
platforms
in both grains
corn wheat notes and difficult food
matrices such as spices chili powder and
black pepper
along with cocoa and a traditional
chinese medicine
using a standardized testing procedure
in addition to the aflatest wbsr plus
immunoaffinity column
it was evaluated for its ability to bind
steromycetin
which is another potent liver carcinogen
and a precursor to aflatoxin
in the results shown here
different concentrations of acetonitrile
are passed over the column at different
spiking levels
this chart shows acetonitrile effect on
afla test wbsr plus
recoveries
and as you can see in this for the two
nanogram mix and the 500 nanogram mix
there are very excellent recoveries
along with
great
percent cvs
the afflicate wbsr plus column was also
compared with our competitors columns
using increased solvent tolerance
we saw that aflates wbsr plus can
tolerate up to 40 percent methanol and
30 acetonitrile over the columns
this is based on 100 nanogram total
aflatoxin spiked into 20 percent of
cedar nitrile and a pbs solution
as shown here you can see that g2
recovery was
very good for the aflatest wb sr plus
column and the competitors had low g2
recoveries along with one competitor
that had a low aflatoxin b2
recovery shown here is the linearity and
lod and loq for spiked corn samples
as you can see the lod and loq are
within
regulatory limits for both the united
states and the eu and the linearity
showed recoveries
for the two nanogram to 500 nanogram
from 96
to 100
along with linearity of an r squared of
0.999
which is excellent
as mentioned previously
the aflatest
wbsr plus immunoaffinity column is also
capable of capturing the precursor to
aflatoxin stc
the scc recoveries in spiked corn
samples are shown here
the structure is also shown
next to the peak in the uplc
chromatogram from the analysis of an
extract of corn spiked with
25 micrograms per kilogram of stc
the recoveries ranged
in levels spiked from 4 to 50 micrograms
per kilogram from 92 percent to 98
percent and the cvs also were below
eight percent which is a very good for
this analysis
shown here is naturally contaminated
corn using a 90 acetonitrile extraction
and an 80
methanol extraction and in comparison
you can see for the higher level
naturally contaminated corn
the trilogy result that we had received
was 301 parts per billion and when we
ran this using our extraction
we received a 301.3
ppb results
with the methanol extraction you can see
that it was a bit lower for
the result compared to trilogy's result
which was
280 in comparison to the 301 ppb
this shows that higher levels of organic
extraction clearly
extract
aflatoxin out better and also with our
column being able to tolerate the higher
solvent it makes for an overall better
extraction with immunofinity cleanup
so one method was used for a complex
sample matrices analysis
10 grams of sample was weighed out
and
100 ml of 90 of senior nitrile water was
added to that into a blender and blended
for three minutes it was then filtered
ten mils was diluted with thirty mils of
two percent tween pbs
ten mils is passed over the afla test
wbsr plus immunoaffinity column
the column was then washed with
two times
of 10 ml of water
and it was eluded
with acetonitrile methanol at a one to
two ratio
the extract was then diluted and
injected onto the hplc or uplc
shown here are the results for wheat
oats cocoa black pepper and chili powder
in respect to their spiking levels
aoac recommended recoveries were 40 to
120 for the lower levels and 60 to 115
for the higher levels in which we fell
into the recommended range
for all of our
matrices using this method coupled with
the new immunoaffinity column
traditional chinese medicine was also
extracted using this method and the menu
column the afla test wbsr plus amino
affinity column
and the fallopia multiflora results are
shown below
spiked at 5
micrograms per kilogram and 20
micrograms per kilogram the aoc's
recommended recoveries are
75 to 120 for the 5 microgram
and 70 to 125 for the 20 microgram per
kilogram the rsds were all in range and
the recoveries were all in range ranging
from 93 to 105 percent
with the highest rsd being of 4.1
which is well within the limits for the
aoec recommendations
and also showed that this will work for
traditional chinese medicine as well as
spices and oats and corn
shown here are the hplc conditions for
aflatoxins we used an alliance
e2695 with a fluorescence detector that
had a photochemical reactor
we used a novapack c18 waters column
the column temp was 25 degrees c sample
temp was 25 degrees c the injection
volume was 50
microliters the flow was 0.8 mils a
minute
and the mobile phase was water methanol
5545 isocratic the software was waters
and power software for the system
the uplc conditions for aflatoxins are
detailed here
the lc system was a waters acuity uplc
h-class with fdn sample manager
the detection was an acuity fluorescence
detector with a large volume flow cell
excitation was 360 emission was 440.
the column that was used was a uplc
acuity hss t3 column
column temp was 25 degrees sample
temperature was 25 degrees c injection
volume was 3 to 6 microliters and the
flow rate was 0.3 mils a minute the
mobile phases were 55 45 water methanol
isocratic and the software that was used
for data reduction
was waters and power software
hplc and uplc chromatograms are shown
here
the one on the left hplc chromatogram
with the red and the green lines the red
line is unspiked black pepper and the
green line is spiked black pepper with
four ppb total aflatoxins and as you can
see there is no matrix interference in
the blank sample
the uplc chromatogram on the right
is from the analysis of an extract of
fallopia multiflora spiked with five
microgram per kilogram of total
aflatoxin
and shown below that is the aflatest
wbasr plus column
some of the advantages of the afla test
wbsr plus immunoaffinity column are
listed here
high performance
the aflatest wbsr plus method exceeds
aoac method performance requirements
giving
greater than 90 mean recovery of
aflatoxins b1 b2 g1 and g2
in both grains
corn wheat notes and difficult to
analyze food matrices such as chili
cocoa and traditional chinese medicine
the column and the method is
comprehensive
bicam's aflates wbsr plus immunoaffinity
column binds aflatoxin b1 b2 g1 and g2
as well as aflatoxin m1 m2 and stc
the method is flexible it's one
standardized method that is suitable for
a wide range of different commodities
it also has a wide testing range
aflatest wb sr plus can detect total
aflatoxin levels from
0.05
nanogram to 500 nanograms
with recoveries greater than 90 percent
the aflatest wb sr plus
method exceeds aoac method performance
requirements and shows that it is
capable of getting excellent recoveries
on both grains
and complex sample matrices
it is fast and easy
the uplc option provides an opportunity
to shorten the analytical runtime and
the use of a large flow cell in the
fluorescence detector
eliminates the need for post column
derivatization
and lastly we have overall performance
these methods have the desired
sensitivity selectivity
and overall performance that is
used to check compliance with regulatory
limits for aflatoxins
in a wide range of crops
and foods
what vicam delivers vicam delivers
testing options and programs to monitor
mycotoxins in a wide variety of
commodities
we are dedicated to ensure that our food
supply is mycotoxin free and safe for
human and animal consumption
i would like to thank you so very much
for joining me today
and for your interest in
the new technologies for complex
matrices and solving some of the
difficult challenges that occur when
analyzing difficult matrices
i hope that you have found this
particularly helpful
and that you will join us in the future
for other
topics
thank you so much